welcome everyone to today's session
i'm excited to see so many of you
joining and hopefully what we will be
able to provide you with
is a brief view of the topics that we'll
be covering
as well as introduce you to the main
program
coordinator dr sono vasudevan and some
of the other participants and partners
that we have
joining this program to talk about their
need for
research and using bioinformatics and
using data science
so my name is elia brodsky as solandi
already mentioned i'm one of the
co-founders of pine biotech so i wanted
to kind of briefly
introduce what we do why are we
organizing this program
and where can you envision yourself
applying bioinformatics after completing
a program like this
so probably many of you have heard about
the genomic revolution right and so the
genomic revolution started
uh in the 20th century we're now in the
21st century so it really started in the
past
century but it didn't happen so long ago
and over the past
50 or 60 years there has been a
tremendous
growth in the type of
sequencing data interest in the human
genome and other
type of genomic data and really a
revolution going on using such genomic
data in many different
aspects of biotechnology agriculture and
biomedicine
and essentially what genomics often
boils down to is analysis of the genomic
code to identify
variation and that variation could lead
to
these changes in the phenotype so
essentially
the change in the genomic sequence could
lead to a change in the way that cells
tissues and organisms look and function
and those could be
diseases or they could be natural
variation
like different color of skin different
length of your eyelashes
or maybe even different height and
things like that so
what we uh think of typically when we
consider genomics is this idea of
finding bugs in the code right so if
those of you that are coming from an
engineering background maybe familiar
with
coding and data science having code
work perfectly is almost impossible as
you're developing that code and so
oftentimes
finding that bug can really help you
understand what is going wrong with a
function
or some kind of an algorithm that you're
trying to run now where is genomics
applied especially in the area of
biomedicine
genomics is extremely important for
understanding drug metabolism
so we understand how different proteins
are
able to process different types of
chemicals
and typically drugs or those chemicals
that we want
to make sure that they're metabolized
properly
you can also think of genomics and
application to cancer so
somatic mutations and tumor development
inherited mutations like in sickle cell
anemia
where the adaptation to different
diseases has led to these phenotypic
changes that are now
causing some kind of a susceptibility to
disease
rare genetic diseases that
could be linked to a elements in our dna
and also drug resistance and obviously
now living in this pandemic
we know about genomics so much more
because it's been in the news it's been
in the
media everybody knows about the
mutations the variance of concern
everybody has been hearing about this
and so it's an extremely
important domain for research but also
an application
to different areas in biomedicine in
fact today
genomics is truly in the clinic and so
you can see
here an example of a report that is
being
produced to kind of establish risk for
developing certain types of
conditions and this is a routinely used
method
in the medical field today at least in
some of the western countries and so i
think what's very important is that
genomics is moving away from just being
purely in research
and being actively used in clinical uh
in the clinical setting and we see this
as a very important development
primarily because the cost of sequencing
is much lower availability of reference
data
is much greater and so there is already
a clear and established relationship
between specific
changes in the dna code and specific
diseases and conditions that could be
clinically categorized
but it hasn't always been like that and
even today there's an
active research also on the
impact of specific mutations because if
you consider
how these mutations occur and how do
they actually lead to diseases
it's a complicated coordinated kind of
an effect of multiple multiple factors
so here you can see
the significance of dna variation in
cancer where
acquired mutations germline mutations
mutations in different types of genes
and in dna repair genes all of those
come together to form
a certain level of risk after which
there could be
an event that could trigger some of
those important changes in critical
genes
and ultimately lead to what we know as
uh
unregulated tumor growth and development
and so these types of changes
are really important for us to
understand from
the basics of genomics and the basics of
what this data could show us about these
diseases
because detecting those changes early on
and also knowing the context of specific
mutations can really help us understand
how to treat diseases that previously
were essentially untreatable
now more than just individual mutations
there are many different types of
mutations so there are many different
types of variations
like multiple nucleotide changes at the
same time
changes that accumulate in a specific
region
maybe translocation so certain regions
even
moving to another position or maybe copy
number variation right so
many different types of changes in the
dna and importantly
it's not just the human dna but also the
dna
of many different other bacteria
viruses and parasites that are important
for
the disease progression and treatment
and so i hope that in this program we'll
have an opportunity to see
how genomic data could be used to
understand many of these conditions
and how can we study genomic data so
that we understand
the important factors that are
that are essentially critical for
understanding of disease
treating disease tracking epidemics like
the epidemic that we're seeing now
or other potential epidemics that we
might see
in the future but i think the critical
part
of this program is that it will provide
you with
an insight about next generation
sequencing data
how that data is generated what does
this data really represent
in terms of the technical part of
genomic
data sequencing and then we'll allow you
to
evaluate some of this genomic data using
these practical data sets that we will
take
to understand where do we see just
simple
variation where can we track mutation
how do we then categorize mutations
and understand what do these mutations
really
mean for the phenotype and so we will
make sure that in this program
after you complete the training you will
be able to understand
the different terminology of what is
a nucleotide how can we categorize
different changes of nucleotides
how do we then annotate those
nucleotides and how can we
essentially find this association with a
phenotype
including some examples of what these
phenotypes might
mean now all of this together
is really the domain of bioinformatics
because bioinformatics combines
informatics the information technologies
that allow us to
retrieve store annotate and efficiently
use different types of
information statistics or using
statistical methods to be able to
analyze such data and the domain where
we apply this
in the domain of life sciences or
biology so
that includes biological research
biotechnology agriculture genetics and
biomedicine
and essentially because of this growth
of
data the availability of data and the
need to
use this data in a meaningful way we
have developed this omics logic training
that includes different types of data
repositories mentorship and training
and this program is one example of such
training that we offer
to be able to equip the next generation
of life science researchers clinicians
and industry professionals that will
essentially transform the way medicine
is being done
the way that new drugs are being brought
to market and the way that we
can innovate early discoveries that will
inform different types of
applications in the future so the reason
why we call this
omixlogic is because the data that we
are describing here genomic data
is just one of the omics data types that
is becoming more and more useful
and prominent in this field and so
omixlogic combines different
user-friendly tools
including different methods of
statistical analysis and machine
learning
it includes the logic behind
experimental design
so that we can understand the technical
variation in the data
it gives you access to big data mining
tools that you can easily use to study
this data
and it provides also examples of how
this data could be efficiently analyzed
to spot significant changes in the
context of real world studies
and so this omixlogic
program is one program that is going to
be
available on june 21st and it provides
you with a complete
road map to get started and learning
about bioinformatics and about genomics
in general so
in this program you'll be able to find
data sets explore them and visualize
them
understand research methods and get
insight and understanding potentially
leading you to
an independent practice project that you
can develop in a short period of time
so to kind of give you a little bit more
detail
about omics logic and beyond this
program that we're discussing today
what it offers i would just briefly ask
all of you
to go to our omixlogic portal
which is learn.omixlogic.com
and so i am uh sorry posted in the
wrong chat here um okay thank you very
much
so um to uh kind of give you a sense of
how this program will work
and how all of this content is going to
be organized
let me briefly show you how you can get
started today
so if you go if you could go with me to
our portal and please let me know
in the chat once you are there
okay you can put there or yes or
something
you will find that there's a
button to log in and you can create a
free account
on here or log in with your social media
so i want to show you briefly how this
is going to work
okay thank you brazili manali
all right thank you so much so please
let me know once you're in and you've
registered
punita
okay anyone else if you already have an
account
once you log in and you're in
you can go right here to programs
and on the program page you will find
genomics in the virtual lab and so this
program right here
is going to provide you with all of the
information about today's session
and what you will learn in this program
and
after a few minutes we will hear a
little bit more
about what are the different topics and
how this is going to be
delivered so here you can see
an overview of the schedule
and some of the important tools that you
will get access to so let me
briefly tell you what are some of these
program resources
that you will be getting access to as a
part of this program
so for different parts of the program we
will
leverage omix logic resources that are
designed
to help you learn about genomics and
this includes a synchronous coursework
with theoretical material quizzes
and practical assignments our
cloud-based analytical server
where you can analyze large genomic data
and visualize results
the onyx logic code playground when you
where you can practice coding in
r and python as well as a repository of
project examples that will guide you
from
data the logic of the analysis
to the practical exercises that you can
replicate
the analysis that was described in the
publication
so first of all we will have an
asynchronous course that you can join
and
a lot of this you can actually start
looking at for free
which is an introduction to genomics if
you're absolutely new to genomics this
is the place to start
you can go to this course to understand
the applications of genomics
some of the basic terminology maybe some
refreshment of your molecular biology so
you understand what is dna
how is it translated into proteins and
things like that
and then you will also learn about how
genomic data is generated
and how you can analyze this data to
extract meaningful information from it
so to get started you actually don't
need to know a lot of coding all you
will need to know
is the logic behind what you are trying
to do so what is the data described
and how you might potentially analyze
this data
and so that is going to be done using
the t-bioinfo server which is a
big data analysis platform that provides
you with easy to use
graphical user interface where you just
push buttons
and get some kind of a result
immediately
and so on this platform you will see
these maps
logical maps of complex analytical
pipelines
that will allow you to process data from
raw format
to a structured format and once that
analysis
is done you will get introduced to
important functions
and tools using r and python that will
provide you with a clear
insight about how coding is a critical
component of bioinformatics
and what you can do using these existing
packages to quickly get results
of sequence analysis and
annotation so again we
hope that this can get you started and
even before this program is launched you
can start learning about the
fundamentals of genomics
of code and analysis and the
applications of bioinformatics
about this kind of biomedical
these kinds of biomedical applications
so now
to talk a little bit more about genomics
in the virtual lab which is
a an intensive program that is intended
to provide
some of the basic material and the
grounding in genomics as well as see
some of the potential
applications of genomics to biomedical
challenges
i want to describe how these programs
are going to leverage from these
asynchronous resources that i briefly
spoke about
and give you an opportunity to immerse
yourself
into this genomic data analysis
experience
that will combine interactive sessions
on zoom like we're having today
self-guided study materials that you
will have access to
and some of these practical assignments
that will include in-class
assignments but also assignments that
you can do yourself and then present
your results
to your peers and to the mentor of the
program